there's a famous list of questions which
is called the Proust questionnaire
called that because Marcel Proust
himself answered it in his teenage years
then it was discovered and this this set
of questions were reviewed is very
insightful great at getting some answers
that would tell you all about a person
from the interviewee so they've been
used by a number of different sources to
interview actors for example Vanity Fair
has been using it for quite some time
and brain pickings recently had a piece
about that I saw this and I thought that
might be interesting to go through and I
think you might enjoy if you haven't
done it already
formulating your own answers for this
but I'm going to give you what my
answers are a transcript for this will
also be available I had to think about
some of these a bit and I actually had
to ask my wife about one of them but
most of them were fairly easy for me to
answer so for each of these I'm just
gonna read the question and then I will
tell you my answer that I've written
down here question 1 what is your idea
of perfect happiness being healthy
having the people I love and enjoy all
around having plenty of time on my hands
to be able to talk with them and also
work on the sorts of projects I enjoy
question 2 what is your most market
characteristic getting into the things I
end up devoting much of my time thought
and effort to in not very well thought
out ways many of my relationships
whether work friendship or romantic have
been like that but so have my studies
and the work I've done number three what
do you consider your greatest
achievement learning how to love other
human beings the ways that I ought to
and the ways that they ought to be I'm
nowhere near done with that number four
what is your greatest fear dying without
getting to do the things I now realize
are the most important valuable or
useful number five which historical
figure do you most identify with
I don't really know is there some person
who is both talented and a bit lazy and
who struggled with his temper throughout
his life nobody comes straight to mind
number six which living person do you
most admire Alistair McIntyre the great
moral philosopher who's shown himself to
be the real deal when it comes to virtue
ethics he has a great body of very
thoughtful writings has done a
significant part of practical work and
hasn't let any of it keep him from
remaining a real human being
number seven who are your heroes in real
life I was lucky in that I've had three
fathers each of whom has made a
significant impression on me my adopted
dad Tony who died when I was 11 my
stand-in dad Fran who was there in my
teens and who is still around and my
biological dad who had been lucky enough
to meet and get to know these last few
years number eight what is the trait you
most deplore in yourself my temper which
can be overly vindictive foolish and
petty at times number nine what is the
trait you most deplore in others
disloyalty to those who have shown them
loyalty number ten what is your favorite
journey I like to hike in Lapham peak
Park number eleven what do you consider
the most overrated virtue niceness
number twelve which word or phrases do
you most overuse you know and so
followed by something number thirteen
what is your greatest regret that my
wife Andy and I didn't go out much
earlier and get married back then number
fourteen what is your current state of
mind as I write this rather tired at the
end of a long day of work number fifteen
if you could change one thing about your
family what would it be we'd see each
other much more often
number 16 what is your most treasured
possession
my dad's banjo which I've had since he
died and played since high school number
17
what do you regard as the lowest depth
of misery the loneliness that comes from
fighting with those who you love
number 18 where would you like to live I
love it here in Milwaukee having
returned after being gone for 20 years
but if I could have another place
Portugal
like number 19 what is your favorite
occupation applying and explaining
philosophy with others number 20 what is
the quality you most like in a man
honesty real straightforward honesty so
you know where they stand and thus know
where you stand as well number 21
what is the quality you most like in a
woman the same why would it be any
different number 22 what are your
favorite names those I make up for our
pets and for my children the pets love
them the kids not so much and the final
question what is your motto philosophy
into practice is the one I use for my
business reason I oh now what exactly
does that mean people ask me and that's
the start of a longer conversation
really that's what a motto is for
you